how do you feel that people these days
are approaching classical players I
think they're having different
approaches for sure that's so my feeling
and it's it's it makes a lot of sense
because chess has changed obviously very
much with the with the new technologies
and and the the engines of course in
general to me it's it's it's an
interesting question whether you should
uh give the same emphasis to starting
the classics nowadays for example
example as it was in my time of course
in my time uh there were I mean that
that was the main tool or one of the
main tools there were not simply there
were not other approaches like uh
computers and and and and so on
so um I think it has some value still
but um probably not the same the same
weight as it uh as it had 30 or 40 years
ago